- On this episode, I
talk music, I talk mum,
and I talk about London
'cause that's where I'm at.
Play it up, guys.
(crowd whoos)
(theme music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the
♫ #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 149
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It is a beautiful day here in London.
What square are we in?
- [Mimi] Uh.
- [Gary] Parkour Park?
- [Voiceover] Grosvenor.
- [Gary] A Gussit--
- [Mimi] I don't even know.
- As you can see, we are,
we are on the other side of the pond.
I'm excited, I'm clearly here
for the New York Jets game
on Sunday, which I'm very excited for.
You saw my official
prediction yesterday, 19-14,
very excited, so I feel
like we're going to win,
since I am three for three this year
predicting Jet games.
Didn't really want to
get too much of a crowd
for this filming, but then got
kind of nostalgic real quick,
and started putting out
some stuff on Twitter.
So, a couple of our
friends have joined us,
and so we're scrapping Kat, I'm sorry,
I know you're going to
play the India roll today,
we're going to go in
a different direction,
and we're going to actually
just do a series of
questions from you guys,
like we did in the park
in Madison Square Park in New York.
So, Staphon, we can do a little match-up,
a little London-New York
stuff in the future,
as a greatest hits show.
149 is here.
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation a little bit
about yourself, because you're
living the life of something
that I believe true when
I wrote Crush It! in 2009,
so that makes it fun for me.
- Hi everyone.
Well, first of all, thank
you for having me here.
Hi, guys.
And, I love your energy, I
love Gary because you and I
really vibe similarly.
We're all about hustle, and,
if I have to talk about myself,
I'll start with the fact that
- [Gary] Do It.
- [Mimi] I'm a hustler. (both laugh)
Um, I come from Azerbaijan,
so I was raised in USSR,
moved to Canada when I was
16, now I live in London,
so my third home.
You know, don't come from a lot of money,
basically my parents
didn't give me anything,
'cause they didn't have a lot.
- Sure.
- So, I had to hustle myself,
you know, through school,
worked two jobs, you know, went to school,
paid my way through school,
then decided to drop out
and started a business with
now my husband Alex Ikonn.
- Alex, get over here, you're
not doing anything behind,
you're not doing anything
behind the camera,
- [Mimi] (laughs) Who's
going to do the camera?
- [Gary] I'll do the camera.
Fine, Alex.
- No, come back here.
- [Gary] They look good,
look (talks rapidly)
Oh, DRock, this is not that hard.
Alright, go ahead, Alex.
- I feel like a block away, man.
- [Gary] So, Alex, go ahead,
you pick up the story.
- What?
- So, basically, we're,
we're a dual couple.
We have a few businesses,
one of the main ones is
Luxy Hair.
It was started, the whole
marketing was just done
on YouTube, and it was super organic.
We basically just made
videos showing how to use
our product, which is
clip-in hair extensions.
- And, something that
Mimi just learned today,
I was telling about, I'll say,
she's like, so, who's Gary,
who's this Gary guy?
I'm like--
- I know, I've seen some of your--
- Yeah, get in--
- [Gary] Wait a minute, wait a
minute, this is upsetting me.
- (both) No, no.
- I'm just kidding, I was just kidding.
Get in there.
- [Mimi] He's just your
biggest fan, like a huge fan.
- [Alex] No, no, you know,
what I wanted to say was that
our business that we built
was inspired by Crush It!,
and it was a lot, I'll be honest, because,
what Gary did with the
wine, at that a time,
we're like, you know what,
this is it, this is the future,
this is how business will be done.
And, we truly believe that going all in,
providing full value to
people, and only thinking
about value, so, the
way we we roll is like,
pure jabbing.
We're jabbing so much, we're
not even right-hooking.
But, at the same time--
- [Mimi] We're not--
- [Gary] Look, right-hooks
happen by proxy.
- Exactly.
- Let me just check on
the camera, make sure it--
- [Mimi] (laughs) Alright.
- [Gary] Not a problem.
Alight, so let's--
- [Mimi] Let's get the shot.
- [Gary] Let's get the show going.
- [Mimi] Yeah, let's get into the show.
- Any, any, oh actually, @Kat, get up,
I'm gonna let you have this part.
get in here and have the India part.
Well actually, you know
what, why don't you tell
the Vayner Nation about
yourself, because you've been
sending some videos to me
as well, so that's exciting.
- Hi everyone, I'm Kat,
and I live in London.
I'm originally from Poland, and yeah,
we had to link to get on the show.
- Exactly.
- So Kat, we're going to
do the India part here.
Let's
- [Kat] get
- [Gary] get into
- [Kat] the
- (all) the show!
- Cool, alright.
Let's, why don't your guys stay here.
Why don't you, let's fire,
Kat, why don't you ask
a question, 'cause it'll give you a second
to think of a question.
- [Mimi] Yeah.
- What's in the DNA of a good sales pitch?
- What's the DNA of a good sales pitch?
- Yeah.
- Um, I think the best DNA
trait of a great sales pitch
is predicated on
reverse-engineering what that person
actually needs.
Way too many people try to sell,
it's really jabbing and right-hooking.
Most people want to sell you
what they want to sell you,
versus what you need.
So, one of the reasons I
think I've been successful is,
whether I'm selling a bottle of wine or
I'm selling myself or
I'm selling VaynerMedia,
I have a thing, but I'm
reverse-engineering you,
meaning, people used
to come into the store
and one of the things I was
proud of is, people would say,
Do you have a good red
wine that I could have,
and I would always say,
Well, what are you going to do with it?
And it was stunning to me how
many people were taken aback
by that, because every other
liquor store, wine shop,
- [Mimi] Why that?
- [Gary] would just, give them
something they wanted to sell.
Oh, I'm giving it to a boss.
Well, then I would go
with something that had
name brand equity that
made them look good.
Or, I'm trying to impress wine friends,
I'd give 'em something nerdy.
So, in their DNA, the core DNA,
is reverse-engineering,
and I think the other part
that really matters, Kat,
is, I do think passion and energy sells.
Like, monotone, not
caring, like not believing.
So, I think fundamental,
100% all-in belief
and then reverse-engineering
what they need.
- That makes sense.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for being on the show, alright.
- Okay, I got two, but I'll
start with the main one.
- Yes.
- Why do you, why do what you do?
What gets you out of bed in the morning?
Like, what's the main
purpose of what you do?
- For me, it's pulling at
two opposite directions.
One is very noble and one is very selfish.
One, I'm aware, and even
before Alex, like, I'm aware
that my biggest fans are the
ones that have felt the effects
of all of my free information,
and it has fundamentally
changed their lives.
- Yup.
- The thought that a human
being could stand right now
and say, Our hap, like,
our great thing is based
on the blueprint that
you put out to the world,
that is mind-blowing.
The selfish part is, I want to win.
I wanna, I wanna, I wanna grow,
I wanna build big businesses,
I wanna buy the New York Jets,
I want to accomplish
things, I want stuff for me
from a legacy standpoint,
not necessarily the money,
but that I'm that guy, that
I created the blueprint,
the future business and
marketing, and I wanna build
an empire, an empire, on goodness.
- Right
- You know, when I look at
the way Steve Jobs' position,
he was a genius and
everybody looks up to him,
but he wasn't great to people.
I don't want that.
I want to be the version of
that where everybody also
comes to my funeral because
I was such a good guy.
- Okay, second one, can I go first?
- Can you go, yeah.
- Okay, so what's one question
that nobody's ever asked you
but you ask yourself all the time.
- You know, I always ask,
the question that nobody
can ask me that I ask myself is,
my own personal question of,
Am I happy?
The biggest fear I have in
life is that I don't accomplish
the things I think I'm
entitled to based on my talent,
and that as I get older,
I become more bitter.
But it's easy for me now
to give away so much,
but if I'm 80, and I didn't get there,
am I going to look back
for 60 years and say,
ah, it's because I didn't
throw enough right-hooks,
it's because I didn't get my fair share.
And so, I'm always asking myself,
are you okay with what you're doing?
Are you okay with what you're doing?
Because you're putting
yourself in a position
where you might be regretting
what you've decided to do,
and so, I fear that, and so,
that's the question I ask myself.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Awesome.
- [Mimi] Very sincere.
- Alright, girls, get outta here.
Let's go, next.
Get in here.
Tell the Vayner Nation who you are.
- Hi, I'm Christian Tierney,
I'm an 18-year-old entrepreneur.
I run Ireland's fastest
growing music channel.
I pick big musicians before they're big.
I've worked with Macklemore,
Ed Sheeran and James Bay.
And, my question is, which
musicians are doing the best
in social and what are
they doing that's so good?
- Truth is, you're so much,
you're way better in a position
to say, answer that question than I am.
I'm not paying attention
to what a lot of musicians
are doing, but I'll tell you
that the musicians that are
doing it best will understand
the framework that created
the greatest bands and
artists of all time, which is,
again, it's the theme
of the show in London,
it is providing value.
It is so easy to see what
Talyor Swift is doing,
it is so easy to understand
what Phish and Grateful Dead
and Dave Matthews Band did.
It is disproportionately
helping an audience,
and then leveraging that
to get them to buy in.
So, whoever right now
is replying to people
on Twitter and video,
randomly creating meet-ups,
like, put, saying happy birthday
to fans, randomly knocking,
where are the artists that
are knocking on fans' doors,
and they open it up, and they go, get.
Whoever's doing the things
that nobody else is doing,
that the fans want, which is the touch.
- Taylor Swift is into that?
- Taylor Swift is perfectly
executing it, and it matters,
and it becomes word of mouth.
And so, I don't know specifically.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But whoever's bringing
disproportionate value
to the people that are potentially
interested in her music,
and notice, I said potentially
that's the key.
Whoever is doing that,
that's who's winning.
Alright, man.
- Thanks so much.
- You got it.
- Really appreciate it.
- Alex, do me a favor,
make sure you round up
everybody's Twitter
and Instagram accounts,
so that we can give everybody the plug,
so the Vayner Nation can dig into his
disproportionate ability to
discover up-and-coming artists.
Get in here.
- Hey.
- Get in here, go, go.
- Hi everyone, I'm Nancy
El Gaudi, at Nancy ElJudge
on Twitter, (laughs) a
little plug (laughs).
So, as someone who is just working out
building their personal
brand, would you say,
quality of concept is more important,
or quantity of content.
- Both!
- Okay. (laughs)
Should I be putting out stuff every day?
- Yes!
- What if I'm not passionate about it,
what if I'm just going--
- No!
- No, only stuff I'm passionate about.
- Yes!
- Okay, cool.
- And now, the question
becomes, do you have enough?
- Right.
- And that's why I just did
that funny little exercise with you.
Guys, we're not all entitled
to have personal brands
and make millions of dollars.
- Yeah.
- It's predicated on
if you have the skill.
Like, I really knew a shitload about wine.
I really know a shitload
about business and marketing.
You clearly are doing your thing with him.
Like, you have to decide if
you're actually good at it
and you have enough, but
you're gonna need both.
- Yeah.
- And, if you're great,
and you got the content,
you can do both, but that's where
the rubber hits the road, right?
Like, you know, building a
personal brand is just like
becoming a rock star,
musician, or a famous athlete,
or a politician.
We don't all get to do it,
but you know what's cool?
Unlike the way our parents grew up
and our great-grandparents grew up,
we all get a chance.
We all have a camera and a
phone, and we all get a chance.
But, the cream is going to
rise to the top, my friends,
not everybody's entitled
to be a personal brand.
- Okay.
- making millions of dollars doing
what they want to do at all times.
It's just not that easy.
What's special is that you get to find out
if you're good enough, because
there was millions of people
that were good enough, but
didn't live in Hollywood,
that didn't have parents that
could send them to Hollywood.
And, that's what's special, not if you,
that we're all going to be famous,
it's that we all have a
chance to create something.
- [Nancy] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- I really appreciate that.
- Thank you.
Get in here, let's go.
Let's go, big man.
- Hello.
- [Gary] Get in here.
- Danny, my name's Danny.
- [Gary] Danny.
Good, Danny.
- So, (chuckles) my mum started
a clothing business a few years ago.
- Okay.
- A kids' clothing goods business.
- So, she wants help building our brand,
but then, the selfish part of
me is focusing on my business,
viewing myself as a
entrepreneur and whosoever.
- Yes.
- How do I balance my
self-desire with my real desire
to help my family and help
my mum do what she's doing.
- That's a great goddamn question.
So, a couple quick questions.
Is your mom, since she just
started, so, small business?
- Yes, quite small business, quite small.
- So, I would tell you, Danny, that
you got something really going for you.
Here it comes, guys, get ready.
How old are you?
- 21.
- 21, perfect.
Kinda thought that's where we were going.
Danny, most people, so,
one thing that's really
pissed me off about London so far,
is I've been running around to meetings,
starting at 4 PM, there's been
millions of people at pubs,
and, I'm like, are these people working?
If you follow me on Snapchat,
you've already seen what, I'm angry.
So, anyway, taking a step back,
you're 21.
You can stay up 18 hours a day.
I know that you ran out
of, like, class right now
to be here, so I guess you
gotta balance some school hours.
But, how many, how many,
I mean, you got hours.
- Yeah, hours.
- Right?
So, I work two full-time jobs every day.
I work 18 hours a day,
that's nine hours every day.
That's more than a lot
of you work, in half.
A lot of people who are watching right now
don't even work nine hours.
I work 18, that's two.
So, I think you can do both.
- Cool.
- You just hafta go to less
pubs, go watch less football,
as you call it, soccer, you
just hafta to less shit,
like, stop chasing the girls, or whatever.
You just gotta, you gotta
work, if you want it.
And, if you don't, what
you gotta do is figure out
what balance you gotta do, and
whether it's 60/40 or 50/50
or 90/10, for your mom, for you,
whatever you break it down
to, the way to really fix it
is by more, having more hours.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And so, I've been able to
solve a lot of my concerns,
my ambition, my work-life balance,
on just doing more hours to a net score.
Just depends on what you want.
- Thank you.
- You got it, man.
- Thanks so much.
- Good.
Alright, let's get in here.
- Hey, man, once again.
- Once again.
- I'm Phil,
- [Gary] Phil?
- Phil Sheikh, from
Chainy.com, and, basically,
I want to ask you two small questions.
The first one would be, do you
believe that unique content
is not the way to go anymore?
- Meaning?
- Everyone's trying to
product unique content.
- Yes.
- Because it is the way that it's set up.
- Okay.
- Do you believe that the process
of creating unique content
is what's going to create engagement?
- Meaning?
- So basically, instead of you producing
a nice piece of content for me,
- Yes?
- that I go to someone
and I create a, a process
where millions of people
create that unique content
and then--
- A platform?
- Yeah, more or less, because, basically,
instead of engaging with
people just towards the end
of the product you are producing,
you engage with them
throughout the process
of making this product
that you're presenting.
- Are you recording the, that, or
- Yes, it's all part of the process.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that's engagement,
an interaction with other people,
I think there's potential
in something like that,
for sure.
- [Phil] Okay.
Alright, and one more
question, what do you think
of Casey Neistat's
Beme, have you tried it?
- So, I'm an investor.
- Okay, that's something.
- So my, my, my thought of it
is disproportionately jaded,
not to mention I love Casey.
He's been on the show, as you know.
I think it's absolutely going to happen.
Of course, I desperately
want Casey to do it,
because I'd love him in it,
and I've invested in the company,
but, right now, the amount of people that
would be interested in seeing
what I'm seeing is high,
meaning, I really would
actually, I don't, so,
I don't love music concerts so much,
but I would absolutely right
now, if Beme worked at scale
the right way, the way
I see it in the future,
through glasses or contact
lenses, if I could watch
what Taylor Swift is seeing
when she's performing
in front of a hundred thousand
people at Wembly Stadium,
that'd be cool, I'd watch
that a little bit, right?
I'd love to watch what
an athlete is seeing
as they're going on the field.
Or, me in a business
meeting, just like as I enter
and how it flows, how my,
you could actually really
figure me out, of how I
sell, just by how I behave,
if you actually saw how I am seeing it.
- Yeah.
- So, I think first-person
viewing and disappearing,
the way life actually
works, is gonna win in the,
so, I hope he wins, but, so,
I believe in the thesis 100%,
because, look, the
contact lenses are coming.
- Yeah.
- Like, they're coming,
and you're going to be able
to record and watch.
They're not even going to
be knowing if somebody's
recording or watching, so
that means we're all going
to be living and believing
it's always going on.
- Yeah.
- The world's going in a
very interesting place.
So, I think he's, it's
very progressive and
I'm excited about it, I think
it goes way beyond the phone,
and that's why I'm bullish on it.
- Well, thank you so much, see ya.
- Thank you, man, thank you.
Guys, thanks for having me.
- [Voiceover] Gary, one more question?
- Yeah, you, get in here, brother.
I love it, I love it.
Good hustle.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Hold on one second. (crew laughs)
Go ahead, go ahead.
- Alright, yeah, so, Alex
Ikonn, you can check me out,
Alex Ikonn, we created Luxy
Hair, Five Minute Journal,
the product will be counter coming out.
So, the question to you
is very business-related.
- Please.
- As you know, we built
something similar to you,
we got inspired off of Crush It!
- Yes, yes.
- So, did the same
thing, did a lot of jobs,
put in a lot of work over the years.
- Built leverage.
- Yeah, built leverage,
put the trust in the brand.
- We have a substantial
business now in seven figures.
- But, now that, it's been
a couple years
we've kind of stagnated.
- Yeah.
- Because, so.
- Happens all the time.
- So my question to you is, and I think,
one of the weaknesses
here, is actually scaling,
because we tried to do
everything ourselves,
we have a small team,
but how do you actually
build that team with you, and
the most important question
is that, how do you build
and maintain that culture
and that, that love that, the same love
that you have for the business,
- In other people?
- In other people.
- (laughs) This is a very, this is a very
eastern European question,
is very common things that.
So, the answer is, you don't.
If you expect somebody
else to love your business
as much as you, you two are
out of your (beep)in' mind.
And, this is something
I tried to teach my dad.
As a young kid, I'm like,
Dad, you own the business.
How the hell do you want them to love this
as much as you do?
What you need to do is
several different things.
First of all, thank you
for asking me the question.
I lived it.
I did it at Wine Library,
from people that are
more like you.
You guys went to zero to
something just like my Pop's.
And how I scaled it was, I
taught him these pillars.
And I taught him these pillars.
Which is, number one, get over that.
It's over.
They're never going to
love it as much as you.
If you're lucky enough, like I find,
like that amazing man behind you,
if you can find people that can
love it 8.5 as much of a 10,
9.2 as much of a 10,
9.7 on a holy grail moment out of 10,
well then, you've won.
So, that's never gonna happen,
and it's actually completely,
completely disrespectful
for you to even want
that from somebody else,
'cause you never loved
somebody else's business as
much as you love your own.
So, why are you going to try
to make somebody else do that?
Number one.
Number two, the biggest mistake
people make at this point
is you start wanting to cash
in on some of the fruits
of this amazing hard work.
It's a little bit more exciting to dress
a little bit better, to
live at a better place,
to take a vacation, to
do all these things.
I get it.
The way to scale and grow
is to have the dollars
to continue to scale and grow.
If you're doing everything yourself,
there's a couple reasons.
One, you're a perfectionist
and don't think
anybody else can do it.
Two, you see other people do it
and they do it as an eight to your 10,
and that's not good enough.
Three, you do not want to
deploy the money because
you want to use those
monies for other things
for yourselves and other things.
All three are massive vulnerabilities.
Fix those three, and you'll grow.
I run my businesses the first five,
10 years of their lives at no profit.
And I did it, and people
can say, now, easy for you.
Bullshit.
I was 28 years old, I
build a humongous business,
and I was making $40,000 a year.
I had friends that were half
me and a hundredth of me
making more money, had better
cars, were having more fun,
I was 28 years old,
making $40,000 a year,
and I build a $30 million
business at that point.
That's eating your own dog food.
So, get over yourselves,
and be thankful that people
want to work for you, and get
them to an eight or a nine,
and you get them to an eight
or nine, by loving them more.
What you did for your audience,
you need to do for your
employees 10 times more.
Biggest mistake entrepreneurs make,
they treat their employees worse than
they treat their customers.
Biggest mistake.
Treat them better than
you treated your audience.
Then they'll get from a six to
an eight, and that's amazing.
They'll never get to a 10.
It's not their business.
Number two, decide how much
you want to live great now
versus every dollar, every dollar,
you take that trip to
Spain, is three dollars less
that you make three years from now.
- Well, what if you have
still substantial money
after vacations, after
everything, and you--
- Invest it.
- And into?
- People.
- But, people, how do you
find these people who are
still eight even or a seven?
- But easy, because you
need to treat them better,
because you've got them,
you just need to change
the way you treated them.
And, if they don't get
there after you treat them
way better, you fire
them, and you find people
who do react to you giving them more value
than they're providing you.
- Cool.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- Really?
- Not fully.
- So, that's why I'm not letting you go.
Here's my thing: you kick it.
So, how many employees do you guys have?
- Uh, around the world, seven right now.
- Great, you need to really vet them,
the number one thing I
would do if I were you is,
I would call them right
after the show, and say,
What can I do to make
this much better for you?
- We do that.
- Good, good.
Do you deliver on everyone?
- Yeah.
- Great.
Well then, you should
be having no problem.
Then, then, I'm a little
bit more confused.
Then, either you have not
built up enough trust with them
for them to tell you the truth, or,
you're just not hiring fast enough.
- We're not hiring fast enough.
- Good.
- 'Cause no, because we're,
we're, we're trying to have
everybody be like fully 10.
- So, you know, (laughs)
- [Alex] We want Eric's--
- [Gary] Eric, Eric was
what number in place, 17?
17.
He watched Vayner go from 17 to 200,
then, for personal
reasons, he went to Boston.
He's back now, and we're 600.
What Eric can tell you
(laughs), all the VaynerMedia
employees from 17 to
200, stick with me here,
this is not an insult, he
knows how many four, five, six,
seven and eights.
You need four, five, six, seven
and eights when you're big.
You can't make seven 10's,
that's not how you scale and win.
That's the secret.
It's not about you guys
getting seven people to a 10,
it's about you hiring 40 people at eights.
- Okay.
So how about this, here is
the last question, follow-up.
So, we're at six, seven
right now, but it's for many
businesses, we're trying to split them up.
It's actually a question
I wanted to ask you
for a very long time.
If you're starting--
- Hold on, if you had a
question that you've wanted
to ask me for a very long time,
how the hell wasn't that the
question you started with?
- You needed that preface.
- Got it, okay, go ahead.
- Okay, so the question is,
knowing we have a successful business,
we have money in the bank,
everything's great,
business is still growing,
everything's awesome,
- God bless, go ahead.
- Yay (chops words), but, the thing is,
who would be your first
five, like, you have,
say, customer service hired.
- Yes,
- And, well, a marketing person, but
who'd be your next five hires.
- I'd have to look at your
business and understand,
so, first of all--
- E-commerce.
- So, first of all, I'd reverse--
- Product.
- First and foremost, I would
reverse-engineer you two.
Whatever you two like doing
the most and are the best at,
I would surround the hires around that.
I'd let you continue to do that,
'cause a lot of people try to replace
the thing they're best
at, that's a mistake.
Stay doing what you do
best at, and whatever
the two of you collectively
do the weakest,
that's when you hire, in
order, five next people.
- Alright.
- Whether that's finance, HR,
product, e-comm, technology,
whatever they are.
- But, what's been your most
best hire for you in that first
kind of, in that Wine Library
when you scaled,
what was one of the best hires
for you, that, you're like--
- The best hires I've ever made
have been the friends that I've hired.
That's the big secret for me, but--
- Position-wise.
- Probably the financial
people, you know, like the
CFOs, the lead financial person,
have been the best hires,
'cause they've given me a context to, hey,
'cause I'm so aggressive, I
want to spend every dollar,
so that gives a vulnerability.
The reason I've never
got out of businesses is,
I'm so much better at
selling than everybody else
in the world, I can always keep the flows,
even against my enormous investment.
Um, I, so, I, at VaynerMedia,
I would say, Marc Yudkin, a lawyer,
creating Legal in-house was a huge hire,
Kelly, an early mananging director because
she created a lot of context,
and then people that look like
Eric which were
disproportionately talented
and open to allow me to mold,
because we were all playing a new game.
People that are moldable but
talented are very attractive.
- That's a good one, yeah, cool.
- Thank you.
- Appreciate it.
- Alright guys, we're
seriously late, right?
Yeah, okay.
Guys, thank you so much, that was good.
That little, that's
like, that in itself is
a separate video altogether. (all laugh)
Operations.
Guys, thank you so much, watching 149.
That's about it.
Statement of the day,
I'd love to understand
what you guys thought about this, and
you keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.